نائب وحاكم مقاطعه خيرسون الموالي لروسيا
كاريل ستريمو صوف ان الجيش الاوكراني تكبد
خسائر كبيره جراء محاوله هجوم فاشله على
مواقع الجيش الروسي الشماليه خرسون
تظهر مقاله انه اعتقاله مواطنين اوكرانيين
كانوا يخططون لتنفيذ ما سمتها عمليات
ارهابيه في مدينه خيرسون الواقعه تحت
سيطره الروسيه والتي تتعرض لقصف اوكراني
متكرر واضافات وسائل الاعلام الروسيه ان
اجهزه الامن تمكنت ايضا من تعطيل سياره
مفخخه وفقا لوكالتي ريا نوفسيه الروسيه
بثت وسائل الاعلام روسيه عبر من التواصل
لمشاهده للحظه وقوع اصابات جراء قصف
اوكراني اصتادف حافله في منطقه دوناتس
شرقيه البلاد وقال عمده المدينه ان سائق
الحافله اصيب بجروح جراء القصف الاوكراني
على المدينه